watch as lefties unravel because you
don't need a mask to travel now we're
forced to fly with liberal gripers
instead of useless face diapers
true we can finally show our faces and
it's enraging hysterical Nut Cases yeah
masks are coming off faster than Jesse
Waters toupee at bedtime
[Laughter]
I'll never get used to seeing that on my
nightstand
yesterday U.S District Judge Catherine
Kimball Mizell struck down Biden's mask
mandate that required face coverings on
planes trains and buses the bite
Administration already plans on
appealing the decision you still have to
wear them on the New York subway of
course but that's mostly the block the
smell of urine
now that the Mandate has been ruled
unconstitutional the TSA announced
they'll no longer enforce masks at
airports no word on the
constitutionality of airports charging
40 bucks for a tuna sandwich am I right
and some of the media were not pleased
and decided to take it out on the judge
if you think she was not qualified to be
a judge after at least graduating from
law school imagine how not qualified she
is to make Public Health decisions about
trying to control highly infectious
deadly pandemics a judge Who was
appointed by Donald Trump in the last
days of his presidency found unqualified
by the ABA and she was 33 years old when
she was confirmed many other judges have
found that this mandate was was legal it
is a crazy way to have a Judicial System
oh get a grip tubing
I mean that psychologically but he can
take it however so at the heart of their
argument she's from Florida appointed by
Trump at only 35. when they can't make a
good legal argument they assassinate the
character but they can go after
themselves The Masks are off which means
the next time I'm duct taped to a seat
it'll be for fun
cat aren't you interested in the
holdouts like why people are freaking
out so they latched onto the mask of
some kind of identity component it's
become and I've said this before a human
bumper sticker like it says who you are
you can't take it off yeah I wonder how
long they're gonna go with it yes
because people are still going to wear
masks to be like I'm I'm one of the good
ones yes but it sucks to wear a mask
like everybody knows that so I wonder
how long that they'll keep it going but
also I feel like if all this stuff was
true there would have been some pushback
rather than okay she says no we won't do
it anymore you know guy it goes back to
the thing where there always has to be
two sides so it's like if they if the
left sees like hey Fox News is heralding
the then they go like wait they think
the match should be off we should say
that it's on definitely say that it's on
I feel like it's an arbitrary
uh position today it's like tribal
negative partisanship for sure and I
think we might need a remedial
discussion in this country about the
difference between something not being
required and something being banned
right because people are treating it
like this judge just banned masks in
America yes and they're defiantly still
wearing them and taking Brave photos of
themselves in their mask like they're
sticking it to this judge no the whole
point is we can make decisions for
ourselves based on our own risk profiles
and if they want to wear 17 masks for
the rest of their lives that's weird but
like go for it and I've seen the videos
like on airplanes of people cheering and
whooping and celebrating I was on the
Acela coming up here last night when
this came down and the conductor got on
Mid train ride to announce that this was
no longer required and there was no
cheering no tears like tears over the
many masks why are they doing this
although secretly people were sort of
looking around off
okay masks for like a good number of
people because it's silly and cloth
masks are pointless I always wear a mask
on a train
[Laughter]
I would like to know what caused the
laugh like
I don't know I don't know why it just
smells on trains you know what I'm
saying Susan here's what do you wear
them on planes no because okay planes
smell nights with the HIPAA air yeah the
HIPAA air I love it what about the class
distinction that we that masks seem to
purvey is that the right word purvey is
that even a word it's a word convey yes
convey convey purvey is when you try to
convince a cat
today
conveying a class distinction when you
sit this is so weird when you sit down
to have something to eat at a restaurant
you're not wearing a mask and
everybody's serving you is wearing masks
yes I find that really bizarre because
it lays naked lays bare the classic
distinction between the people who work
the service provider yes and that
bothers me pay for the service that's
got to stop don't you agree so you think
we should be equal yes and Communists
and social eggs
it's like wow this is I'm a free market
anarcho capitalist so I'm hoping though
on airplanes and I'll be one the first
one to say it and you know I'll I'll
take the backlash but if someone's sick
and coughing while I'm eating my
prepared microwave meal in economy class
I think they should be wearing a mask I
mean you know it has some etiquette use
the right Forks at dinner and put on a
mask if you're sick sorry I'm
situational though that makes sense yeah
yeah we're not saying it should be
banned we're just saying you know you're
a typical choice plus everybody we have
a mask on and they sneeze they pull it
down to sneeze yes yes all the time I've
seen it so many times even as they pull
it down because you don't want to get
boogers in your own mask exactly have
you ever projectile vomited while
wearing a mask oh what a mistake that is
I just like when in turbulence I'm
pulling that thing down Joe and I'm
puking all over you fair enough yes it's
only be an improvement they need to come
up with a combination mask coexist
bumper sticker yes and then you can you
can turn yourself into a human Subaru
and let everyone know where you stand on
every issue it's a fair analogy because
they're treating it like it's part of
it's an identity component like just
like a bumper sticker which tells you to
visualize World Peace you know if you
went up and peeled that off they would
be pissed yeah it's a flag and and like
you said no one's no one's taking their
masks away yeah you can wear as many
masks as you want for as long as you
want it's so strange it do they think
that it's never going to end I mean the
1918 pandemic ended and there was no
vaccines back then yeah and it killed a
lot of people unfortunately but there
has to be a point where we come out of
this but they don't want to let it go
because they have this irrational
feeling that like you said that if it it
seems trumpish on this side well then
I'll wear 30 masks and I'll wrap my head
in duct tape and that's what you want to
do go right ahead but other people are
ready to get on with their lives we've
made it through we're coming out the
other side let people get back to normal
lives yeah it's a good movie ending when
it's a trump-appointed judge who makes
the best political decision and that was
like I don't know when they appointed
the judge how long ago was 2020 2020. it
was right on his way out yeah it's like
it's just a nice finger in the eye hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else